AIRCRAFT.
I'M GRIFF LIVE IN LVIV.
NOW BACK
>> Greg: HAPPY WEDNESDAY
EVERYONE, EXCEPT YOU STEVE IN
POTTSTOWN, PENNSYLVANIA.
I CAN SEE WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND
IT'S SICKENING.
AT LEAST DON'T DO IT IN FRONT OF
ME AND PUT YOUR NOODLE IN THE
OTHER ROOM.
SO YOU WANT TO SEE HOW POWERFUL
THE MEDIA INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX IS.
WATCH THOUSAND THEY CREATE
SOMETHING OUT OF NOTHING SO THEY
GET EVERYONE FROM REPORTERS TO
POLITICIANS TO WASHED UP
CELEBRITIES BUYING INTO IT
BLINDLY.
DAVID COPPER FIELD HAS NOTHING
ON THEM.
I REFER TO THE PARENTAL RIGHTS
BILL IN FLORIDA.
EVEN RIGHTY WEB SITES CALL IT
CONTROVERSIAL EVEN THOUGH THE
BILL IS ONLY CONTROVERSIAL
BECAUSE THE MEDIA LIED ABOUT IT.
THE BILL BANS CONSTRUCTION TO
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND GENDER
IDENTITY FROM KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH THIRD GRADE.
THE ONLY PART I FOUND
CONTROVERSIAL IS THE THIRD
GRADE.
HOW ABOUT TEACHERS OF ANY GRADE
STAYING OUT OF YOUR KIDS PRIVATE
LIVES YOU POWER HUNGERIES.
LIKE MY EXTRA NIPPLE THE BILL
SEEMS PRETTY BENIGN TO ME.
LAST THING I WANT TO TALK TO A
KINDERGARTENER ABOUT IS GENDER.
THE SECOND TO LAST THING I WANT
TO DO IS TALK TO A
KINDERGARTENER.
AND IF ANYONE TRIED TO TEACH ME
THAT STUFF WHEN I WAS THAT AGE,
IT WOULD SCREW ME UP.
I WAS STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
FIGURING OUT THE ANATOMY OF KEN,
AND NOT THE DOLL.
THE BUS DRIVER.
BUT IF THIS BILL UPSETS YOU,
THAT'S ON YOU.
YOU'RE WEIRD.
SERIOUSLY, ARE YOU REALLY THAT
PASSIONATE ABOUT KIDS IN
KINDERGARTEN LEARNING THIS
STUFF?
THAT SPELLS CREEPY WITH A
CAPITOL K OR MAYBE IT IS IT'S
ONE BIG VIRTUE SIGNAL.
DID ANYONE CARE TO READ THE BILL
THE OUTRAGE WOULD DIANE THEY
WOULD HAVE TO LET GO OF THE LIE.
SO THE MEDIA COULDN'T READ IT
AND AS LONG AS THEY DON'T THEY
CAN SAY IT BANS THE WORD GAY.
IT'S THE MEDIA VERSION OF A
JUSSIE SMOLLETT HOAX AND FRANKLY
MAKING ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
SOMETHING YOU HAVEN'T READ ISN'T
JUST DUMB, IT CAN BE DANGEROUS.
EVERYONE ALL RIGHTY, SIR.
I DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO READ
YOUR CHART JUST YET BUT I DID
HEAR SOMEONE IN THE HALLWAY SAY
WE HAVE TO REMOVE YOUR APPENDIX
AND TESTICLES SO LET'S GETS THE
PANTS OFF OKAY.
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
THERE'S NO WAY THE CHART SAID
THAT.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD READ IT.
>> I WATCHED DON LEMON TONIGHT I
THINK I KNOW WHAT I'M DOING.
>> WHAT DOES HE KNOW.
>> WE MAY BE DOCTORS BUT HE'S ON
TV.
GROW UP.
>> YOU DO RAISE A GOOD POINT.
I GUESS I'LL PREP NOW FOR
SURGERY.
>> Greg: SO YOU'VE SEEN DON'T
SAY GAY IN THE HEADLINES BECAUSE
THE MEDIA WON.
THEY PUSHED THE LIE KNOWING
THEIR PEERS WERE TOO LAZY TO
CHECK IT.
THEY WERE RIGHT.
AND WHAT HAPPENS YOU CREATE A
MENTAL ILLNESS CAUSED BY FAKE
NEWS WHEN ADULTS REDEFINE
HYSTERIA AS ENTERTAINMENT.
>> WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A GREAT
NIGHT TONIGHT, AND FOR YOU
PEOPLE IN FLORIDA, WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE A GAY NIGHT.
GAY, GAY, GAY, GAY, GAY.
GAY, GAY, GAY.
GAY.
>> Greg: WOW.
HOW EDGY, CHANTING GAY IN FRONT
OF A LIVE AUDIENCE FILLED WITH
NOTHING BUT ULTRA LIBERAL
HOLLYWOOD SELECTS.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO NEXT
FEED A CHRISTIAN TO SIMBA AND
MUSTAPHA?
HOW ABOUT A DANCE NUMBER ABOUT
RAISING THE MINIMUM WAGE.
TURNS OUT READING SCRIPTS ISN'T
THE ONLY TIME FIX COMES OUT OF
ACTORS MOUNDS.
THEY'RE SO PLEASED WITH
THEMSELVES LIKE DRIVING A PRE US
TO A PRIVATE YET.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS IN DELUSION
YOU THINK AIR YOU'RE SHOWING THE
WORLD YOU'RE THE SMART ONE WHEN
YOU'RE ANYTHING BUT.
LOOK AT DISNEY WHICH CLAIMS RON
DeSANTIS WANTS TO ERASE GAY KIDS
AN ODD POSITION FROM A COMPANY
WHOSE CRUISES ACTUALLY GO TO
COUNTRIES WHERE HOMOSEXUALITY IS
A RACE IT'S BANNED.
IT'S CHEAPER TO VIRTUE SIGNAL
THAN ACT ON YOUR PRINCIPLES.
VIRTUE SIGNAL IS THE ONLY THING
THAT'S FREE IN DISNEY.
THE MAGIC IN MAGIC KINGDOM IS
HOW THEY MAKE $10 STAT FOR A
SODA.
THEN THERE'S ACTOR RON PEARLMAN
WHO USED THE THINK FOR HIMSELF
BUT NOW HE'S LET TWITTER RUN HIS
BRAIN.
APPARENTLY THAT'S ALL HE READS
SO THAT HERE HE IS GOING OFF ON
THE BILL.
MUCH DON'T SAY GAY?
DON'T SAY?
THAT'S THE FIRST TWO WORDS IN A
SENTENCE SPOKEN BY A POLITICAL
LEADER OF A STATE IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA?
DON'T SAY?
DON'T [BLEEP] SAY YOU [BLEEP]
NAZI PIG.
SAY.
FIRST AMENDMENT.
READ ABOUT IT.
THEN RUN FOR OFFICE.
YOU PIECE OF [BLEEP].
>> Greg: I GET SO HOT WHEN HE
GETS SO BOTHERED.
SO CLEARLY THAT IS NOT A HEALTHY
MAN.
THAT'S SOMEONE INFECTED WITH A
MIND VIRUS THAT ESCAPED FROM A
DISNEY LAB IN ANAHEIM AND SPREAD
BY THE MAIN STREAM MEDIA.
BUT HE TOO IS ALSO A VICTIM
DUPED BY TO SUCK PEOPLE LIKE HIM
INTO A RAGE.
THAT'S WHAT THE MEDIA WANTS, THE
MORE PEARLMAN YOU GET THE MORE
MONEY YOU RAISE.
YOU GET SOMEONE TO RAGE AND YOU
NEED ANOTHER FIX EVERY DAY.
AND WITH USEFUL IDIOTS LIKE HIM
DISNEY WON'T NEED GOOFY.
MAYBE IT WILL OFFSET THE MONEY
THEY LOSE ON WOKE MOVIES.
IMPORTANT PEARLMAN USED TO BE IN
SONS OF ANARCHY NOW HE'S SON OF
SAM A GUY HEARING UNTRUTHS FROM
HIS DOG PLUTO AND THE ABILITY TO
INTERPRET WHAT'S HE WILL RADIO.
ALL HE GETS NOW IS FREE
PUBLICITY.
IF CASEY'S WATCHING AND I DOUBT
IT OR HE WOULDN'T FALL FOR THIS
CRAP BECAUSE THIS I REHAB FOR
PEOPLE WITH MISINFORMATION.
THE BILL BANS TALKING SEXUAL
GENDER OR IDENTITY IN K THROUGH
THIRD OR A MANNER THAT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE FOR STUDENTS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH STATE STANDARDS.
THAT'S IT.
THE BILL DOESN'T BAN THE WORD
GAY NOWHERE DOES IT BAN CASUAL
DISCUSSIONS REGARDING SEXUAL OR
YEP STATION OR GENDER.
AND TEACHERS, UNDER THIS BILL,
THEY CAN'T TEACH ABOUT BEING
STRAIGHT EITHER.
AND THAT'S THE ONLY GROUP WITH
NO PARADE.
>> PERIOD.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
SHE HAS MORE GRIT THAN A
SANDPAPER FACTORY, COHOST OF THE
FIVE, JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO.
>> JUST LIKE YOUR DEAD BEAT DAD,
HE LEFT THE HOUSE AND HE'S NEVER
COMING BACK.
FORMER GOP CONGRESSMAN AND FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JASON CHAFFETZ!
AND SHE'S BEEN ON MORE THIN ICE
THAN BRIAN BOYTANO, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND HIS POCKET SQUARE IS A
BLANKET.
THE NWA WORLD CHAMPION TYRUS.
I'M HYPERVENTILATING.
THAT'S A QUICK WAY TO GET HIGH
JUDGE.
CAN'T ARREST ME FOR THAT.
>> Host: I WILL A TRY
>> Greg: ARE YOU
HYPERVENTILATING TO GET BUZZED
LET ME MEASURE YOUR BRAIN SELLS
YOU'LL SAY AND THROW ME IN THE
CLINK AND THEN CUFF ME AND
THEN --.
>> Host: WHO KNOWS THAT WILL
HAPPEN THEN
>> Greg: MY BRAIN GOES TO THE
DARK PLACES JUDGE.
HAS DISNEY LAND BECOME THE
PLAYGROUND FOR SATAN?
>> Host: THE DISAPPOINTING PART
OF IT NOW IS FOR ME DISNEY IS
THE PLACE TO TAKE YOUR KIDS AND
GRANDKIDS BUT NOW THEY CAN'T SAY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OR BOYS AND
GIRLS THEY HAVE TO SAY DREAMERS.
AND BY THE WAY WHAT IS
CALIFORNIA, THE WORK PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA, HOW DARE THEY IMPOSE
THEIR CONCEPTS OR THEIR IDEAS ON
FLORIDA WHICH OVERWHELMINGLY
SUPPORTS THIS BILL THAT DID NOT
FOR ONE SECOND DOES IT SAY DON'T
SAY GAY.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU I USED TO
LOVE SONS OF ANARCHY.
RON PEARLMAN YOU JUST LOST ME.
I CAN'T STAND YOU.
YOU KNOW WHY?
YOU'RE STUPID.
STUPID.
I DON'T CARE HOW BIG YOU ARE, TO
GO OUT AND SAY YOU'RE A NAZI
PIECE OF [BLEEP].
YOU DIDN'T EVEN READ THE STUPID
BILL.
YOU ARE A STUPID
>> Greg: I LOVE IT.
YOU SWORE.
>> Host: I DID?
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> I QUOTED.
YEAH, AND YOU'RE A PIECE OF
[BLEEP], TOO
>> Greg: OH, I'M NOT GOING TO
SLEEP TONIGHT.
JASON, DISNEY I THINK THOUGHT
THEY COULD USE THEIR MUSCLE ON
DISNEY AND HE WENT AHEAD AND
SIGNED THE BILL ANYWAY.
IT'S KIND OF BALLSY ON HIS PART,
HE'S JUST DOING THE RIGHT THING.
>> RON DeSANTIS IT'S A SIMPLE
THING AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
TO SUGGEST THAT -- WHERE ARE THE
TEACHERS IN ALL THIS?
COME ON.
YOU'RE A PERVERT IF YOU THINK
THAT TEACHING A SECOND GRADER
ABOUT GENDER IDENTITY IS THE
RIGHT WAY THE GO.
AND I'D LOVE TO HEAR THEM MAKE
THE UNCOULDER ARGUMENT THAT THEY
SHOULD BE INFORMING A SECOND
GRADER, HERE'S SPOT, HERE'S
ANOTHER SPOT, HERE'S SPOT ON
SPOT.
NO, THAT'S NOT THE WAY I WAS
TAUGHT.
>> THAT'S WHY I THINK THE DON'T
SAY GAY THING WAS KIND OF THEIR
VERSION OF DEFUND THE POLICE
EXCEPT DEFUND THE POLICE WAS
ACTUALLY SAID BUT THEY WERE
DOING THAT TO HANG AROUND THE
REPUBLICANS NECK BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO ARGUE THE BILL
BECAUSE IT'S A HARD BILL TO
ARGUE AGAINST.
IT'S KIND OF REASONABLE TYRUS.
YOU HAVE CHILDREN.
>> YEAH.
AND THE IDEA OF A STRANGER THAT
WENT TO SCHOOL FOR FOUR YEARS
TEACH ARITHMETIC OR ENGLISH TO
TALK TO MY CHILDREN ABOUT
SEXUALITY OR ANY OTHER MORALE
DILEMMA, HELL NO.
IT'S ABOUT THE PARENTS.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> WE DECIDE WHAT WE TALK ABOUT
IN MY HOUSEHOLD.
AND IT'S SIMPLE.
IF MY HOUSEHOLD WAS AFFECTED
THAT WE HAD A FAMILY MEMBER THAT
WAS TRANSGENDER OR A SITUATION
THAT DIRECTLY AFFECTED MY CHILD
THEN WE WOULD DISCUSS IT BUT
WHEN THEY GET OLDER JUST LIKE
YOU USED TO WAIT TO TALK ABOUT
THE BIRDS AND BEES 14 OR 15,
YOUR DAD OR IN MY CASE THE
OCCASIONAL BOYFRIEND WOULD COME
BY AND SAY HEY TYRUS, RIGHT?
>> YES, SIR.
>> TALK ABOUT THE -- OH, WAIT.
BUT IT WAS THE PARENTS' CHOICE.
THIS LAW SHOULD NEVER HAVE
NEEDED TO BE PUT INTO EFFECT.
BUT BECAUSE WE ARE ALLOWING THIS
SMALL GROUP -- AND WHEN YOU SAY
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA, IT'S
NOT.
IT WAS LIKE THREE CEOs AND SOME
WOKE PEOPLE WHO HAVE SOME OWN
ISSUES TRYING TO PUSH THIS THING
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING, WINDOW
WHAT WE SAW WITH ROGEN AND
SPOTIFY AND NETFLIX, WHEN YOU
STAND UP TO THEM THEY GO AWAY
BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY HAVE NO
FOUNDATION AND NO FOLLOWING.
THERE'S NOT A MILLION PEOPLE
STANDING OUTSIDE DISNEY SAYING
CHANGE IT.
IT'S THIS GROUP.
AND IF DISNEY HAD ANYTHING --
RIGHT NOW, SIX FLAGS, KNOCKS
BERRY FARM I WOULD START RUNNING
COMMERCIALS, BOYS AND GIRLS,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, COME ON
IN.
>> BRING YOUR KIDS.
>> BRING YOUR KIDS BRING YOUR
FAMILY AND GIVE AN ALTERNATIVE.
YOU WANT TO GO THERE AND PUT
THAT STUFF OUT THERE FIND
ANOTHER PLACE WITH ROLLER
COASTERS AND RATS AND DUCKS WITH
SPEECH 'EM PEDESTRIANMENTS.
>> KAT HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO
DISNEYLAND OR DISNEY WORLD?
YOU DON'T SEEMED LIKE AN
AMUSEMENT PARK PERSON.
>> IT'S FINE
>> Greg: I FEEL LIKE YOU CAN
AMUSE YOURSELF WITH A BRAIN.
I DON'T NEED TO GO TO SPACE
MOUNTAIN WHEN THERE'S SO MUCH
SPACE INSIDE HERE.
NO?
>> I GUESS.
DID I READ THE BILLER NO NOTHING
OR WHAT?
TO BE PERFECTLY CLEAR, I AM A
PERVERT.
I STILL DON'T WANT TO TALK TO
KIDS ABOUT SEX, I DON'T KNOW WHY
YOU WOULD.
THERE ARE TWO WORDS THAT CONCERN
ME WHICH ALWAYS DO ARE STATE
STANDARD.
THAT'S ALWAYS CONCERNING BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT REALLY THE PARENTS
THAT'S THE STATE DECIDING AND
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT ANYTHING
THAT MAKES A RULE FOR A WHOLE
STATE FULL OF KIDS BECAUSE ALL
KIDS ARE INDIVIDUALS AND HAVE
DIFFERENT NEEDS AND IT'S ALL
VAGUE.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW IT END UP
WORKING OUT IN PRACTICE BECAUSE
STATE STANDARDS ARE NEVER, YOU
KNOW, THEY NEVER ACTUALLY SAY
ANYTHING.
BUT, YEAH, THE BILL DOESN'T SAY
GAY IT SAYS SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
I KNOW THESE PEOPLE ARE UPSET
LIKE IF A GUY HAS A PICTURE WITH
HIS HUSBAND ON HIS DESK IS THAT
GOING TO MAKE -- YOU KNOW, YOU
WOULD ONLY GET IN TROUBLE I
WOULD THINK, IT'S ALSO IF PEOPLE
HAD PICTURES WITH THEIR WIVES.
BECAUSE STRAIGHT IS ALSO A
SEXUAL ORIENTATION, I BELIEVE.
SO, YOU KNOW, WE'LL HAVE TO SEE
HOW IT SHAKES OUT.
BUT I JUST THINK IN GENERAL,
LESS GOVERNMENT IN THE SCHOOLS,
MORE OPTIONS F